Basic day as a dietitian would be coming in to work...
...and picking up on referrals that come through from the wards and then assessing patients.
You liaise with many health professionals in the way of nursing staff and doctors,...
...but also other healthcare professionals to do with therapies,...
...so like physio, for example.
For me, the job satisfaction plays a big part...
...and for dietitians and other professions within the NHS,...
...that job satisfaction probably comes from the rapport you get with seeing patients...
...from when they're first referred and following them through their patient journey.
The challenges of working as a dietitian in the NHS...
...is that you are referred many patients and it's keeping on top of caseloads....
...when you have many other responsibilities to take into account.
So, it's the challenges of being able to do that...
...and feel like you're doing a proper job without cutting corners...
...because fundamentally, patient care is a priority.